one plus two a raised to the power of
six this is about as simple as it gets
after 1 plus X all I've done is I've
just modified its number here and it's a
simple one as well okay so here's what
you need to do I'm going to notice do
you remember when we did the powers of 1
plus X or X plus 1 then we write x plus
1 didn't wait okay do you notice just to
make it a little bit logical for
ourselves rearrange the powers of X in
descending order is that right we had
the X cubed at the front and then the x
squared and the X etc so I'm going to be
the same kind of thing here but um I'm
going to do whatever the pruning rule is
and I'm gonna sort of see how I should
arrange this based on whatever is the
first thing so here's what I'm going to
be you think about your powers which
were all my gonna be on it's gonna be
able to one that goes 1 and then sinks
right so I'm looking at my table yeah
1 6 15 2015 6 1 okay that's it so I also
wanna point out the because the
coefficients are symmetrical you
actually can do it either way right
so for instance I'm gonna have 1 6 but
that's a 15 15 20
fifteen six one okay now in the time to
come you won't need to write it out like
this you might need to sort of use the
coefficients first you'll be able to
know the coefficients are well enough
that you can be like oh no big deal I
can just do the mess I go but right now
I really want to highlight to you where
the numbers come up and then what the
rest of the pieces are so what's gonna
happen is well we used to have like X
cubed nails like the first two or in
this case would be next to the six we
don't have an X there we have a two a so
therefore the first term I'm going to
label it as 2 a to the 6 okay so that's
the most of the two ways than I thought
Plus how many two A's am I gonna have
the X alone
it's just gonna climb down isn't it so
this will be fine this one is going to
be four and so on
and there are no two A's left at the end
and that's one of the ways you know
you've done it right sometimes when I
was doing these questions earlier on and
I would do the coefficients and then by
the end of your line uh-oh I've got an
extra turn hanging around that means
I've forgotten one along the way now in
this case it's pretty straightforward
all that's now retired bus it's just to
work out what the powers are and extend
a few things
so I don't know if you're doing your
powers of two really well I happen to
know the to the power 6 is 64 so 1 times
64 and then there are 6 lots of a great
morsi's
powers of n now here you gotta be
careful because the binomial
coefficients that's what we call these
things these guys here the binomial
coefficients start to interact with
these are the numbers over here the
other coefficients and their powers so
to the 5 is 32 6 lots of 32 is a hundred
and ninety-two done to the 4 is 16 15
times 16 I think is 240 oh good 2 cubed
is 8 21 to eight years 160 and it's
gonna keep going from there
so that's it
you're done you expanded the binomial
okay now I just want to point out when
you have a look at the coefficients now
now that I've got these binomial
coefficients and they're mixed together
I've multiplied through River these
numbers here whatever they were
do you notice this thing into power is
rather sorry its coefficients generously
not symmetrical anymore right because
you've got more tools over here and then
you get progressively less twos but it
kind of MUX up the nice perfect symmetry
that we had before okay so one of the
questions that we are going to learn to
deal with not quite yet I just want to
flag it since you can recognize it one
of the questions you have to deal with
is what is the greatest numerical
coefficient that you can see in your
expansion okay what is the greatest one
this time stood at 40 now it is not the
middle term you know is that it's
actually one to the left of the middle
okay finding what this term is clearly I
could expand whole thing up and I can
find out what the term is
but if this power is something else
rather than six like if it's say 11 or
25 I don't really want to write out all
12 terms or all 26 terms it's very
time-consuming so I would teach you a
technique and this comes a bit later but
howdy goes straight to the greatest term
grace coefficient I should say and know
which one it is
without having to do everything from
scratch okay let's have a look at this
next one now I hold your hand completely
to the first one I will do one thing to
help you with the next year before I am
let you have it going just like when I
was doing absolute value graphing okay
this is a difference difference I'm
subtracting but to help me use the
binomial theorem properly I'm going to
write it as a sum so this is the way I'm
going to write it
it's a sum difference but it will help
you not get confused when you deal with
these negative signs so I'm going to let
that sit there you've got your passport
right over there you know which really
going to have a go and see what gender
you can see I've already begun by having
identified the row in Pascal's triangle
that I need okay so here's the fee
thrown sorry here's the fifth power so
here's the fifth right now I'm going to
slot in all of my other terms
so have a look the highest power here
will always be the highest power from
the original binomial okay so in this
case I'm going to have how many powers
of negative 2/3 X 500 done plus now it
is very important that this minus sign
comes along for the ride because when
you have a look at something like this
that term gets raised to the power of
six
this one gets raised to the power of
five well it makes a difference whether
there is a negative sign there sometimes
it won't grow but sometimes it will not
next one minus two-thirds which X ^ oh
and it just climbs down doesn't it
I would introduce a variable pretty rule
that's already been introduced in the
question but I mean you can but you're
not gonna save yourself that much work
because eventually you're gonna have to
deal with the minus 2/3 X at one point
another okay so this is what I've got
and I know it looks somewhat messy but
it's okay it's just a long question it's
not difficult or complex it's just a
little bit lengthy I also want to point
out you notice how long this tower here
I didn't write this power because well
what why is something once is just dad
right but as you see there's actually a
term missing juice is a term on the end
how many minus 2/3 X's do I have on the
final term and so I've got 0 of them but
of course that's why I don't write it
however for the sake of completeness you
can see the pattern works completely
symmetrically and now I have to go ahead
and actually that's expand have a look
how many negative signs are there TUC
tv5 four of them will cancel out leaving
just the one so I write minus 2 to the 5
is we've done this already and three to
five I think is 243 yeah
of course it happens we when we got here
or how many do you sides of it there are
four and therefore they all cancel out
so therefore I'm gonna radar plus I'm
actually going to do it in two steps
because my head hurts
this is going to be this is to the four
is sixteen right
that's moment yeah you've you've already
put them together for time and exit
before obviously if you want to go
straight to eighty quick for you but you
just adding in places where it's like
well if I make a numerical error number
one I guess I don't necessarily see it
number two it's very hard to trace it
back you're like you your answers wrong
but I don't know why because the working
is not there what's the next time next
time are you getting there you're
getting the patent here right so it's
highly symmetrical this plus minus
negative minus plus minus plus etc what
we're gonna get to see in this ten
that's for nine months that's a - hey 27
X cubed what's this sign gonna be bus
now I've got four ninths the next one's
gonna have a sign of - I can do that and
then that's already a plus one hey you
happy with that and of course the next
step is just to actually simplify the
numbers but you guys can take care of it